so ein rotes buch führt dass sich ein
wenig in die irre also müssen es nicht
vielleicht er so ich sag mal schwarz
braun sein
[Musik]
und wir dürfen live dabei sein
beim ersten zusammentreffen der
alternative für deutschland mal sehen
was das für menschen sind die merkel hat
uns wenigstens die türken vom leib
gehalten bis jetzt was die anderen nicht
und wenn die mal nicht mehr da ist haben
wir die sofort da sie versucht hat die
nord türkei bin ich überzeugt wir werden
eine alternative anstreben und zwar zum
wohle des deutschen volkes jahr unter
uns den euro aussieht überlegen man
danke schön so was sie wollen sich am 13
april glaube ich solvay gründung treffen
ist das richtig da soll der versuch
gemacht der versuch gemacht weil es ist
april genau was ich machen soll
ja was soll die frage 2019 oder am 1219
da ist mir dann schon lieber
sie wissen warum ich beim 21 21 uhr sagt
deshalb eine ganz andere überlegung
haben sie einen euro weil die sammeln
wir jetzt ein die werden dann von uns
bzw von mir haben sie dankeschön werden
von uns jetzt vernichtet
dankeschön schönen abend noch ich
versuche mein geld müssen zu retten und
außerdem von unserer wirtschaft sind im
land noch existieren wissen was zu
retten
mit entschuldigen sie ich bin 50
besonders
das ist ja sehr mitgenommen solchen arzt
rufen
tun sie sich das eigentlich angst ich
kann doch schön im schützenverein
unterwegs oder fische züchten und mama
netten urlaub machen wir heute abend
hier sei die urlaube mit meiner mutter
nicht mehr so erquicklich sind oder dem
über 80 ist
ich habe schon gesehen ihr großartiges
buch das ist ja ungefähr die farbe die
auch sarrazin für sein buch immer
verwendet roth dieses rot das letzte von
ihnen weiß letzte von ihnen weiß und
weil das erste von ihm das viel
spannendere das schönere buch das war
rot was ist wenn das auch zwei millionen
auflage hat wir haben ist es so roth ist
ein rotes buch führt dass sich ein wenig
in die irre also müssen es nicht
vielleicht er so ich sag mal schwarz
braun sein könnte auch nur schwach
zahlen aber rot ist eine wunderbare
farbe und wenn die linken sich roth
genommen haben ich lasse mir die farbe
auf der linken nicht vermiesen
karl albrecht schachtschneider um den
mann geht es ist er
parteigründer herr schachtschneider ist
wieder parteigründer noch mitglied bei
uns er unterstützt uns in unseren
politischen ziel aber er gehört nicht
der partei an
sie wissen aber schon dass er damals mit
herrn haider auch zusammen war und seine
politik unterstützt ich glaube nicht
dass er haider ein rechtsradikaler
gewesen ist glaube nicht dass das in
einer form verboten gewesen ist was herr
schachtschneider dort gemacht hat so von
habe ich überhaupt kein problem damit
und nun die barocke möchte ich jedoch
noch mal fragen ob sie die frage ob wir
in die rechtsradikale ecke gehören zum
23 mal das doch ihre frage die sich
immer wiederholen oder nicht
das habe ich doch gerade gemerkt aber
sind die beiden sichern und nicht so
ganz einig aber das kann ja noch werden
viel geben damit zurück ins studio zu
oliver weg nach köln
[Applaus]